i can open bottle of beer with most
things
i think as long as it's like hard and
it's got a round surface i think i could
do that
let's see if i can do that all right and
this will go
if we're in a situation and there is no
bottle opener people just throw beers at
us and i'll adapt
[Music]
hey i'm sam fender and i'm answering the
fans questions on loud bible what's your
go-to takeaway meal i love pizza i love
just burgers on that one i just love
junk what's your pizza topping of choice
pizza topping i'm not going to say it
because it divides people you've got to
say it
i'm a hawaiian guy
[Music]
when i go to italy i haven't ever are
you you're not all you're discussed
today i don't look i don't care i've
seen gordon ramsay kicking off about it
i don't care i like it
i'm going to eat it cry crystal river do
you have any funny fan stories
oh actually this one is quite funny all
the fans send fan mail to shields to my
hometown but they don't know my address
and it goes to the first fender on the
postcode and it's my uncle jamie so
everything just turns up with me on
jeremy's house he's a newcastle fan like
but brings you he's like right so today
we've got chocolate she's like we've got
a we've got a letter from helga she says
i love you you've changed my life
and then he's like oh he's like can i
keep the newcastle socks no yeah you can
keep the newcastle stuff
you keep the chocolate as well who were
your musical inspirations growing up
people kind of
always self-edit these answers and try
to be really cool about it you know
trying to say that like listening to lou
reed when there was six and it's just
not true when i first started getting
into music it was just like good green
day my dad's a guitarist right but he
never really taught us anything because
i think he wanted us to get a real job
but then one day he did teach us
something it was the day that opened up
my world and i was about 10. he taught
us the power chord which is like a
simple like three fingers chord which
can go anywhere across the neck and once
i figured that out it was like
and i was like oh my god that's american
idiot
i was like i am literally a guitar god
like i was like 10 years old do that and
then it was like
dipped
down
that smells like teen spirit i am a
guitar god certified i was just
absolutely lost once you figured that
out i was completely
like
i was flying after that you know it was
every day i was just uh yeah that's just
nonstop
the platinum the bathroom the black yeah
it's so good what is your best party
trick i can open a bottle of beer with
most things
i think as long as it's like hardened
it's got a round surface i think i could
do that
let's see if i can do that all right and
this will go
if we're in a situation and there is no
bottle opener people just throw beers at
us and i'll adapt
who was your first celebrity crush
natalie portman
and it's because she was in star wars i
thought she was the most
the most amazing beautiful person i've
ever seen in my entire life how old were
you like like i'm talking six
all the way through to now i'm still
crushing harder
if you were to grab a pint with anyone
dead or alive who would it be
i think i'd want to pick someone who was
just like going to be good on the drink
someone who's going to be like a right
laugh like a total hell raiser i think
it would be really funny
to go out for a massive night out with
james brown
because i just think
he's like the king of hell raising any
and i mean you'd probably wind up like
dead
where would you go on your night out
just down the fish gate
go down the fish get your north shields
for a couple of pints james brown just
started tearing the place up which fans
are wilder northern or southern northern
france
actually tell you what i'd go as far as
saying scottish fans but the scottish
are just like glasgow just know how to
boot off
it's always like this carnage i mean i
love all of them you know i mean i i
don't i don't care where they're from as
long as they go mental like you know
buzzing what's one item you can't live
without and why it would be my last poll
because when my granda passed away he
left his
700 quid
and i went and got this les paul guitar
not guitar is for me it's like it's me
and me granddad's thing so that would be
the one
let's see what we'll go
oh
greg what will you call this um
you can call that like a a shields dummy
because it's what what you give your kid
to shut up
it's like all all the babies should say
you just see them in the pram